the stars of jurassic park have been in
some certified classics and they've also
been in some of the worst movies ever
made from street to video sequels to
films that zero critics liked these are
the horrible movies jurassic park actors
hope you forget about
you'd be hard-pressed to find a more
reputable actress in hollywood today
than laura dern she has starred in more
than 60 feature films and was even
nominated for two academy awards before
finally taking home her first oscar in
2020 for her poignant performance in
marriage story dern has been appearing
in movies since 1973 and throughout her
decades spanning career she's shown in
some truly unforgettable roles arguably
none more popular than that of
paleobotanist ellie sattler and jurassic
park
if dr sattler is dern's most memorable
role however perhaps her most
forgettable part came years later in
2010's undeniably lackluster little
fockers the third and final installment
in the meet the parents trilogy despite
reuniting ben stiller robert de niro and
dustin hoffman the trilogy capper ended
the once promising comedy series on a
very low note most people probably don't
even remember that this movie exists let
alone that lara dern plays a very small
part in it as an elementary school
headmistress named prudence
ironically enough dern must not have
been exercising much prudence when she
decided to sign on for this terribly
unfunny comedy
before he got ripped to play star-lord
in 2014's guardians of the galaxy chris
pratt wasn't exactly the guy that movie
studios had on speed dial when they
needed an action hero star-lord
who
star-lord man legendary outlaw
fast forward a few years however and
things have certainly changed in
addition to his wildly popular portrayal
of the galaxy's favorite snarky hero in
the guardians of the galaxy movies brat
has also headlined another multi-million
dollar franchise as velociraptor trainer
owen grady in 2015's jurassic world as
grady pratt got to showcase his
effortless acting chops with both bold
unapologetic machismo and grounded
everyman humility he's also been a part
of a movie that failed on almost every
level
movie 43 which was marketed as a
star-studded racy comedy is undoubtedly
the worst film on pratt's resume with a
lowly four percent score on rotten
tomatoes this jumbled mess of a movie
took home three razzies in 2014
including the worst pitcher award while
pratt shouldn't shoulder much of the
blame for the awful final product you
have to assume that he hopes movie 43
never comes up in
interviews jeff goldblum is the kind of
performer who can take virtually any
role and make it a fan favorite his
filmography consists of over 135 acting
credits and is chock full of
unforgettable movies and characters
including seth brundle in 1986 the fly
david levinson in 1996's independence
day and of course dr ian malcolm in
1993's jurassic park
goldblum's unique acting prowess is
beyond question but with such an
expansive filmography there are bound to
be a few misses to coincide with all the
hits
perhaps his most notable failure was
that of 2015's mordecai in which
goldblum plays a shady art dealer milton
krumpf arguably the worst johnny depp
movie of all time mordecai plays like a
cheap austin powers knockoff even the
talented core cast consisting of depp
gwyneth paltrow and ewan mcgregor
couldn't save this action comedy from
colossally flopping at the box office
vincent d'onofrio has a knack for
playing really good bad guys you might
not have even recognized him as edgar
the creepy unwitting host of a nefarious
cockroach alien in 1997's men in black
or as the bald crime boss kingpin in
marvel's daredevil and hawkeye he also
played the main antagonist hoskins in
the head of injin security force in
jurassic world a self-proclaimed method
actor d'onofrio has turned in some
incredibly believable performances over
the years however there have been a few
less than believable performances too in
2017's rings a sequel to 2002's the ring
d'onofrio played a blind caretaker with
a secret connection to the ghostly
samara as peter sabchinsky of
rogerebert.com put it he seems to be
playing the role for an easy paycheck
and absolutely nothing else
not exactly the kind of criticism you'd
expect to hear about an actor who once
gained a whopping 70 pounds just to play
private pile in full metal jacket
this is my rifle there are many like it
but this one is mine
still dinafrio was hardly the main issue
in rings an incoherent film that's
branded with an eight percent rating on
rotten tomatoes
sam neil is no stranger to being in
front of the camera with nearly 150
acting credits the new zealand native
has been performing in movies and tv
shows since the early 70s his most
recognizable role is obviously that of
dr alan grant from the jurassic park
franchise but he's also starred in
plenty of excellent films irresistible
however is not one of them despite a
talented leading trio of neil susan
sarandon and a young pre-famed emily
blunt this 2006 dramatic thriller went
straight to dvd the premise was simple
enough sarandan becomes suspicious that
she's being stalked by neil's new
secretary played by blunt and paranoia
ensues
it's honestly quite similar to other
popular movies like the hand that rocks
the cradle and sleeping with the enemy
but lacks any of those film's ability to
tell a compelling story
irresistible currently boasts a 20
critical score on rotten tomatoes which
could certainly be worse however what's
arguably the grossest facet of the movie
is the uncomfortable age gap between sam
neil and emily blunt neil was born in
1947 and blunt was born in 1983 making
him roughly 36 years older than his
co-star it's quite an age gap even for a
hollywood blockbuster
during a 2020 appearance on the graham
norton show legendary actor samuel l
jackson proudly declared that he loves
watching his own movies
apparently not only does he buy 1 000
worth of tickets for his new films when
they first hit theaters but he also
frequently rewatches his older flicks
when he's bored at home if i'm channel
surfing and there's nothing else on i'll
go into the search engine and go samuel
l jackson i pick one and i watch it
while jackson has been in too many
iconic movies to even name there's one
film in particular that's hard to
imagine he would ever want to re-watch
hold on to your butt
in 2004 oscar-nominated screenwriter
philip kaufman directed a movie called
twisted a mystery thriller that stars
ashley judd as a police detective trying
to catch a serial killer jackson played
the police commissioner who
unsurprisingly is revealed to be the
killer despite the combined star power
of judd jackson and andy garcia critics
found incredibly little to like about
twisted blasting it down to a one
percent on rotten tomatoes
ariana richards was only 12 years old
when she played lex murphy the
adolescent computer nerd hacker in
jurassic park but she was apparently so
good at displaying genuine terror that
even director steven spielberg was
impressed as she told den of geek
when we were filming the scene of the
t-rex with the jeep steven came over to
me once and said ariana you reach such a
deep level of fear and terror what do
you draw from were you scared by a clown
when you were three don't tell me i
don't want to know perhaps one of the
events that richards drew fear from was
reading critics reviews of spaced
invaders a movie she starred in three
years before jurassic park the hammy
sci-fi comedy followed a group of short
bumbling aliens who after overhearing a
radio broadcast of war of the worlds
invade earth on halloween night only to
be mistaken for trick-or-treaters in a
small american town although audiences
didn't seem to hate spaced invaders
critics tore it to pieces and their
reviews roger ebert bashed the film
writing one of the purposes of growing
up and getting an education is to learn
why movies like spaced invaders are a
waste of time
of all the actors in jurassic park only
bd wong returned to reprise his role
that of injen's chief geneticist dr
henry wu in jurassic world although he
was reportedly hesitant to slit back
into dr wu's shoes wong once again found
himself right smack dab in the middle of
a dino disaster the jurassic park
franchise is undoubtedly wong's most
popular work but he's also excelled in
other areas throughout the years
including successful tv series like
gotham mr robot and law and order
special victims unit he also voiced
shang and disney's animated classic
mulan however it hasn't all been
sunshine and critical roses for the
former broadway star in 1998 wong had
the misfortune of starring in the
substitute 2 skulls out a straight to
cable sequel with almost no connection
to its 1996 crime thriller predecessor
wong played one of the bad guys but
honestly the lazy outing is so poorly
put together that the good guys are
pretty bad too the movie has a rare zero
percent rotten tomato score not exactly
the kind of grade you want on your
acting report card
when the fifth wave hit theaters in
january of 2016 it's easy to imagine
that sony and columbia pitchers were
banking on a possible franchise after
all the movie was based on the first
novel in rick yancey's literary trilogy
so there's definitely plenty of source
material to work with
however after an onslaught of dismal
reviews and a very disappointing box
office pull any future sequels seem to
be unlikely at this point are we still
alive
i think so in the explosive sci-fi flick
nick robinson who co-starred as an
angsty teen amidst a dinosaur breakout
in jurassic world plays an angsty teen
amidst an alien invasion co-starring
with chloe grace moretz ron livingston
and leave schreiber the fifth wave cast
tried their best to keep the ambitious
action movie from imploding into a
million pieces but they were ultimately
unsuccessful
while it's hardly the first young adult
novel movie adaptation to flop you have
to assume that robinson wishes he would
have just said pass when the casting
director came calling
have you ever watched a movie that's so
over the top emotional that it seems as
if the whole film was created with the
sole purpose of making the audience cry
that's exactly what it feels like to
watch 1995's three wishes a sappy family
drama starring patrick swayze mary
elizabeth mastro antonio and jurassic
park child star joseph mazzello
the story follows a mother who lets a
drifter named jack stay with her and her
two sons after accidentally hitting him
with her car
as you can probably predict there's more
to jack than meets the eye and he begins
to form a special bond with the young
boys becoming the father figure that
they were missing it's easy to criticize
corny movies like this but people do
find enjoyment in cliched feel good
stories this probably helps explain the
52 audience score that three wishes
holds on rotten tomatoes critics however
have different opinions roger ebert
wrote the movie lays it on so thick that
even with the best will in the world i
couldn't go along on its slow and soppy
ride
for whatever reason film adaptations of
dan brown's crowd-pleasing robert
langdon novels like the da vinci code
and angels and demons are never well
received by critics
even with ron howard in the director's
chair and tom hanks playing the lead the
mystery thrillers just don't translate
to the big screen hank's third attempt
at langdon 2016's inferno was another
example of this inferno starred hanks
and rogue one breakout felicity jones as
the two main characters but it also had
a solid supporting cast including two
guys who had just starred in jurassic
world the year before omarc and the late
irfan khan both actors are extremely
talented c was nominated for a golden
globe for his work on netflix's lupin
and khan accrued a slew of accolades for
his work in both hollywood and india not
even their acting abilities could save
inferno from going up in flames at the
box office
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you